como estas hablan justamente kóvacs la
idea de kóvacs y tener esta plataforma o
esta coalición de países es justamente
poder ayudar a los países que a poder
negociar mejor la posibilidad de tener
vacunas y las negocios participan más de
190 países y lo que se espera es que en
el primer trimestre del próximo año
todos los países un 190 los que son
parte de esta coalición deberán estar
recibiendo las primeras dosis de vacunas
que van a incluir vacunas como para ser
modernas y otras más que están dentro de
las negociaciones
no sé si bien es cierto hay un retraso
esperemos que ese retraso no sea tan
grande como más va a permitir que los
países reciban al menos el 20 por ciento
de las vacunas que necesitan para toda
su población y la idea es que como está
pasando en todos los países se comiencen
vacunando a las poblaciones que se
consideran más críticas personal de
salud y la población vulnerable en
algunos países también se va a incluir
como pasa en el caso del perú en el que
estoy yo
probablemente el personal policial que
va a ayudar a poder organizar todo el
tema de las vacunaciones doctor están
preparados los gobiernos
latinoamericanos para los grandes
desafíos que implican las fórmulas
contra el cob y 19 retos cómo mantener
las vacunas a ciertas temperaturas
algunas extremas la necesidad de que se
apliquen dos dosis por persona para su
efectividad o el conseguir millones de
jeringas y agujas de inyección
bueno vamos a comenzar por la parte de
atrás el conseguir todos los insumos que
se requieren esto es una cosa que los
países todos los países latinoamericanos
han debido estar trabajando durante todo
este periodo mientras se esperaba
evaluar la efectividad para decidir con
cuál de las vacunas se hacían y lo que
se espera y los países han estado
trabajando de manera independiente
algunos también trabajando con la
organización por 'the para medicar en la
salud para poder tener todos esos
insumos esperemos que lo tengan eso es
lo primero lo segundo el definitivamente
es un gran reto vacunas como la de facer
esta vacuna requiere ultra freezer
refrigeración de -70 y tengo que decirte
que en muchos de nuestros países eso no
es posible y va a ser sumamente
complicado probablemente esa es la razón
por la cual algunos países incluyendo ha
habido muchas dificultades en nuestro
caso en el caso del perú porque va a ser
sumamente complicado manejar vacunas
como esas pero tenemos otras vacunas
inclusive por ejemplo la vacuna moderna
ya no requiere ese ultra free se resiste
requiere menos 20 es más fácil y van a
venir otras vacunas y hay otras vacunas
que
se espera que se mantengan que mantener
solamente en las temperaturas que son
las regulares de cadena de frío para las
cuales estamos acostumbrados
definitivamente la vacuna para ser con
menos 70 no es la más adecuada excepto
para algunas zonas urbanas pero para
poder lograr accesibilidad esa esa no va
a ser el mejor camino para mí para
latinoamérica ni probablemente para
áfrica e incluso en algunos lugares en
otros países como eeuu ellos van a tener
dificultades con esta vacuna para
mantener la cadena de frío doctora
patricia garcía muchas gracias ella es
integrante del comité asesor de la
coalición para las innovaciones en la
preparación ante las epidemias